okay
um
um
yes
50 emails
as soon
i know you come here
yeah so we're gonna i think they're
gonna
so sunday's definitely sunday's
happening
they said they're doing overnight sunday
democrats can't tell about their
is
i mean
no i did the math
is
than i was dead
um
all right
i've drawn this so many times
he told me
but you know what i think we could we
can make some chatters
oh
a minute
oh
okay
um
um
um
well it's supposed to be abc and cbs
today
i'm not shorting any gallery
you have four in there
foreign
um
um
um
um
good to see everybody
oh
okay
oh
um
okay go back there
uh
thank you
um
is
preliminary heads up
still we're gonna do like a minute
rotation and then
swap out cool all right
yeah we're just for anyone waiting out
there
and i will still do so
and we're supposed to leave these on now
right that's the latest rules
okay i had a new york yankee one but it
had a strap at the bottom and a strap at
the top and i couldn't quite figure out
what to do what do you do with the strap
at the bottom
no you'll have a bow mine didn't it's a
book because i tied it
about it mine didn't have separate
strings it had
i sort of like the steelers okay
no i hate some teams dallas cowboys
them too yeah okay thank you everybody
and let me thank senators durbin
stabenow warren for joining us
we want to talk about what's happening
to our country and the votes
as they relate today and tomorrow our
country is in
enormous pain we've had 220 000 people
die um millions sick
the numbers going up who gets sick six
million americans missed their rent
payment last month
millions are losing their jobs business
small businesses are going
under left and right we have so many
different problems
and what do the republicans do leader
mcconnell a stunt
they can't get anything done their
caucus is divided
leader mcconnell and senate republicans
are the major barrier to preventing us
from getting a bill
because even when mnuchin calls them up
they say they're not going to do
anything
what was really indicative of what
happened
was what happened at the appropriations
committee
pelosi said our number's 143. mnuchin
says we can get up to 119.
so they decided to have the
appropriators get together
the republican appropriator said our
instructions are to start at zero we
don't have any other instructions
so to when the american people are
suffering
to put this political stunt on the floor
a second time
is cruel is is harsh
and it shows in complete lack of
leadership
and caring for the suffering of the
american people
now what are we doing we are making an
effort to bring to the floor the heroes
to bill
the bill that passed the house that
would have a realistic chance of helping
people
and it has many things in it that are
not in either bill
that is being brought up today and
tomorrow by the republican senate stunt
let me remind you what they are some of
them we're going to focus on three here
one is health care we need more testing
we need more tracing
the heroes bill has 75 billion dollars
and more important
even than the money is a plan laid out
to how to do it because the
administration's been incompetent we
gave the money last time do you know
nine billion is still sitting there
for the states to do tracing and they
haven't even distributed it yet
even though it was passed in the
original cares bill
so we need money for testing and tracing
but we need money for our hospitals
the doctors and nurses and health care
workers we can't
leave them behind
we need money for patients who are sick
none of that first area health care
testing
and helping our health care institutions
and helping the american people when
they need
health care second is schools
we need our schools to reopen safely
safely everyone wants to reopen them we
cannot leave our school children behind
we cannot leave our teachers behind
and those who work in the schools nor
can we leave all the parents behind
who have jobs at work but if their kids
aren't in school what are they going to
do
and the third area we're focusing on
today is small business
this ppbp bill leaves out so much
that the heroes bill has in it no
targeted aid for restaurants
no targeted aid for stages no targeted
aid for minority
businesses no targeted aid for local
news feed here
critical access hospitals and
non-profits
no idle money the money probably that
smaller businesses use
easiest of all because it's a grant
and there are so so there are so many
places where their bills are
inadequate and don't meet the need
so it's a sham because nothing's going
to pass mcconnell can't even put a real
bill on the floor
all he can do is put in a motion to
table and then vote against it
a sham a stunt if there ever was one and
it's the second time they're doing it
didn't work from the first time
won't work for them again and then there
they put poison pills
in their bill tomorrow that they know
democrats won't accept and my colleagues
will address some of those as well
so every day of families are left behind
in so many different ways so we
democrats later today are going to turn
up the pressure on republicans
they're all going to have to cast a vote
whether they want to vote on the hero's
bill or not
which is comprehensive 72 percent of
americans according to new york times
sienna
support another two trillion dollar
stimulus package like heroes half the
republicans do
so americans will see exactly
where senate value senate republican
values are
whether they really care or they just
want to go through a game
and pretend they're doing something
while actually doing nothing at all it's
a damn shame what they're doing
senator durbin
idiots idiots
that's what president donald trump
called the public health experts who
work in the federal government
and he put dr anthony fauci in the same
sentence
i don't think they're idiots i think
they're experts
and this president is uncomfortable
around them because they are warning us
we're about to see a surge in infections
and deaths in america
america sadly america with five percent
of the world's population
and 20 percent of the covet 19 deaths
america just south of the nation of
canada
we have two and a half times the number
of people dying from covert 19 as canada
what's wrong there's no leadership
and that's what it comes down to in this
debate this president
says he's tired of talking about this
coleman thing his people are having
rallies
they're not worried sadly they're in
danger their lives
every time they show up at one of his
rallies we know that
and he obviously doesn't care so the
medical imperative of more and more
infections and more and more deaths is a
reality
do we take it seriously so seriously
that nancy pelosi passed
her covert relief bill five months ago
mitch mcconnell as he brought it to the
floor refuses to
all he offers are these skinny versions
that don't address the real issues
but there's a second reason that this
has now made the calendar
for mitch mcconnell he got the hell
kicked out of him last week at the
hearing of the senate judiciary
committee
witness after witness made it clear this
should not be
the breakneck priority of the united
states senate
covet 19 should be our priority if we're
ever going to save lives
and reopen the economy and so
his vulnerable members needed some cover
and that's what they're going to get
an opportunity for a vote but we know
what's missing
what's missing is more testing at a time
when we desperately need it more contact
tracing at a time we desperately need it
and help for hospitals and clinics and
medical professionals all across this
country
what's missing and help for family
disposal and the bottom line i'll leave
you with is this
he did put his red line in this bill
just to make sure
that it wasn't going anywhere you've
heard him say it over and over on the
floor
nothing's going to pass unless i can
have immunity for liability for the
biggest corporations in america
when it comes to coven 19. the american
people see through that
if mcconnell creates that kind of
immunity what's the likelihood those
companies will do the right thing to
protect their employees and their
customers
we are determined to get a real bill
that addresses a very real problem
thank you good afternoon the people in
michigan the people across
america need help and they need it right
now they needed it yesterday
and you know it's really not stimulus
it's about survival
for michigan families it's about
survival for our businesses
and under the republican bill too many
people are left behind
that's the bottom line instead of giving
people the help they need
they've introduced a bill that ignores
our urgent
testing and other health care needs our
families our children
and far too many of our businesses
if we want parents to feel confident
that their children can go back to
school
safely if we want people to feel they
can open their businesses safely
and get back to work republicans can't
leave millions of people behind and
that's exactly what mitch mcconnell's
bill
does right now it's not safe coconut 19
cases
hospitalizations deaths are spiking
hospitals and nurses are struggling to
get enough ppe
our health care professionals are
exhausted
and stressed and at severe risk of
burnout but the republicans
leave them behind and their bill leaves
millions of families behind
you know the extra 600 a week provided
in the cares package was a lifeline
and it needs to be extended a survey
last month found that more than 25
of michigan residents one out of four
thought they were going to be evicted
or have their home foreclosed on in the
next two months
mitch mcconnell's bill also leaves
hungry children and families behind
we have 40 percent of those who are on
snap
food assistance in our country who've
gotten no additional help
through this entire process of covet
and finally they are leaving far too
many
businesses behind and the employees that
work for them
restaurants and gyms and craft breweries
and theaters
that have revitalized michigan small
towns all across our state
these small businesses need help now in
the initial round of ppp we also as
democrats fought for
30 billion dollars in dedicated funding
to support
minority-owned small businesses and
underserved communities and nonprofits
that also is not in there and they are
left behind
we need to approach this pandemic and
the economic pain
it's unleashed with the seriousness and
boldness it deserves our health care
providers our
children and families and business
indeed help right now
this is not the time to leave anybody
behind and democrats
are fighting to make sure they aren't
thank you
220 000 americans
are dead from covet 19. millions more
have contracted the disease and continue
to suffer
we have tens of millions of people
across this country who are either
unemployed or afraid they're about to
lose their jobs
parents who are struggling because they
can't get daycare they can't get their
children
into school small businesses
that have shuddered and not sure if they
will ever be able to reopen
restaurants who can't see a business
plan going forward minority
owned businesses that have been hit the
hardest and what does mitch mcconnell do
plays politics instead of helping people
this bill that he's putting on the floor
again
is not a bill about helping people it's
a bill about leaving people
behind who does mitch mcconnell want to
leave behind
he wants to leave behind every single
person in this country who is worried
about covid 19.
no help for our hospitals not enough for
tracing not enough for testing
not enough for our doctors and nurses
just leave them behind
and what about parents school children
no money here for the kids who are
caught in between having to try to study
from home parents who are struggling
with that
just leave them behind and this bill
leaves
millions of small businesses behind
restaurants behind minority owned
businesses
behind there are so many left behind
in the mcconnell bill but understand
this the mcconnell train does have some
first class tickets in it
first class tickets for giant
corporations
for giant corporations a release of
liability
no matter how irresponsible they are
they don't have to worry about making
their own employees or their customers
sick
sick to the point of dying mitch
mcconnell says those
folks get a first class ticket on the
mcconnell train
and how about parents wealthy parents
who want to send their kids to private
schools
the mcconnell train says let's have the
taxpayers pick up the bill for that
full tax credit for sending your kid
to a fancy boarding school how about
that in other words what mcconnell's
doing here is playing politics of the
ugliest sort
he wants to stand up and claim that he's
helping the american people
no he's playing the same old game no
help for the people who need it
and lots of help for the people who
don't well that's not where the
democrats are
the democrats are here for working
families for people who are struggling
for small businesses for restaurants
for minority owned businesses for our
doctors and nurses for the people who
are in public health who are trying to
get their arms wrapped around this
covent crisis this is what it's going to
take
not only to deal with this immediate
health care crisis
but also the economic crisis that is
tumbling behind it
that's why the democrats will be voting
no today
questions on this subject yes
um senator mcconnell said that if
speaker pelosi
and the white house do reach some sort
of agreement and that there's a bill
that passes the house
we'll take it up in the senate that
doesn't mean that republicans will
support it but
are you in talks with uh him at
all about the negotiations that are
happening mr mcconnell
leader mcconnell has been dr no when
anyone approaches him including the
administration he has said no
no no so uh we'll have to see if this
latest thing is a change or just another
ruse another trick like they're built
today
he doesn't speak to many people about
these things
how you see um this particular issue
playing out after the election since it
seems like this is not going to happen
before
well look we democrats want to get a big
bold bill that will meet the american
people's needs
as soon as we can so nancy pelosi is
fighting to get one now
and as you know we've been met just with
intransigence by the republican senate
um we will try to get one in the lame
duck and we will try to get one
uh should we win the presidency and win
the senate after that the sooner the
better
but it needs to not leave people behind
it needs to be a strong big bill
this is the greatest economic crisis in
75 years the greatest health care crisis
in 100 years
we need something that meets that that
rises to that occasion and meets the
moment
and we'll fight for it okay yes about
anything for ppp
funding itself if this giant bill
doesn't
go through or get support i mean
businesses are just hurting out there
and some of them are wondering
first of all we don't want to leave
anyone behind
period because you do one thing what
about everybody else
and what about the people you know some
republicans may say did that and i don't
have to do anything else we can't do
that as a country
not as a party but as a country we need
to include all the people who need help
you're going to tell a mother who can't
feed their kids forget it
you're going to tell someone being
evicted from their home forget it
you're going to tell a school that can't
open forget it not
us yes
sure some progressive groups have spoken
out criticizing senator feinstein for
her handling of the hearings
i was wondering when you're making this
criticism and do you plan to make any
changes to the judiciary committee
okay i've had a long and serious talk
with senator feinstein
that's all i'm going to say about it
right now okay
nope can i ask you about north carolina
um republicans are oh sorry
um republicans yeah sorry sorry about
that um
republicans have fused on the um
cunningham's um extramarital relations
biggest issue
yeah and i just wanted to see um do you
are you so confident that cunningham can
win biggest issue in north carolina is
health care like it is across america
the need of americans to be protected
from pre-existing conditions the need of
senior citizens to be able to afford
their drugs
the need of people who don't have health
care to get it that's the number one
issue in north carolina
and that's why we're going to prevail
yes on that topic
obviously we're running this campaign
and against the supreme court nominee
based on health care how is the decision
made amongst uh democratic leadership to
focus
so specifically on health care well
there's a whole number of issues but the
number one issue of salience to the
american people
we you know if you hear the supreme
court the american people say
health care this court will take away
your health care uh oh
and that's why the american people want
us to delay
overwhelmingly we're in the middle of a
great crisis a pandemic
people have needed help with
pre-existing conditions long before the
pandemic
do they want to get insurance a mother
or father whose child has cancer
doesn't want to be told by the insurance
company you can't get insurance and
watch their kids suffer
we believe that's a such an important
issue that it's one of them but we have
talked about a woman's right to choose
we have talked about labor rights we
have talked about environmental rights
we have talked about voting rights we
have talked about civil rights we have
talked about lgbtq rights
they're all important but health care
has been the number one issue out there
in the country
and we chose to emphasize it thank you
everybody
thank you
[Applause]
thank you